and minutes played in miro's absence
and the two of them will begin this
game together and should see a
majority of ice time alongside
one another turned over is San gets it
off for Marchman hand off to Shane he
scores Matt du Shane as the Welcome Matt returns
for the stars on hold ice they've got an early
tally to go up one nothing Jackson L looked
like he was up two mins didn't quite know what
he wanted to do with the puck he basically just
served it up from that all three guys on that
line they've scored the prettiest goals for
this team this season they use one another so
intelligently all three guys touch it again
like they almost make sure pass for San and
wed away now Here Come the Ducks they've got
numbers it's Leon with Carrick Leon waits to
Carrick and lanquist broke it up his pass
coughed up and here comes Terry turning in
off the wing delays kept it low in a pad save
and then a good tie up by Harley collected by
an tavish through center for the ducks on
his blade hands to Terry he shot off the
ball challenged glove side on Andre and Ting
off the iron the stars get it up for Robertson
nice move past lome reaching and catching up no
room there back and a shot they wave it off it
looked like that went in did it not I thought
it did the lights came on they're still on it
fulled 18,500 here the guys working the lights
play goes on the entire time G donov centers
boxs up they had Gibson going the wrong way low
shot turned toide back comes silverberg he shot
and hre made the save opening up here in Dallas
lundestrom behind the net wrap around couldn't
get through and it slipped past Carrick who was
tied up and that's scored from no angle off of
Ajer and in OV vaka Nan ends a chaotic sequence
with a no angle carum to tie the game an absolute
shocker after the wraparound by lundestrom who's
married to that in the game here tonight just a
floater from the angle and I don't know whether
Jake just didn't expect he obviously didn't see
it R hence goes back to W Johnston up to suder
here boards B it towards the slot came to HS
Gibson made the save at leaked to the right and
cleared by Anaheim what a pinball setup for the
stars and Gibson kept it out same thing happened
just a minute ago before they tied it Robertson a
shot vodan and steel cancel Gus's pass BS its
way and then pressure on hackin paon he gets
written off Henri alone Terry scores the Ducks
got the puck on the wall and they found Troy
Terry who had so many chances back in the first
he capitalizes early in the second yeah I mean
if if you were going to wager something to say
well who's going to score for the ducks in the
game after watching that opening Frain it would
be Troy Terry that's just Yanni Hapa is usually
a real firm guy on the puck he just got mauled
by the guy we were talking about off the Hop Adam
Henrik on the boards feeds it to Terry in front
and bang aable to get it out of the duck third
now on the near side kept in again this time
hackin stopped vodan Nan's bit steel nice slip
pass pavelski turned aside and Co casin in down
on a knee Ross Johnston pushed it too far forward
and then filled in the stars foxa getting back
defensive Zone stars on the attack Harley left
Circle bounced off Gibson he made the save and
pinball back getting kept out and then Smith's
chance stopped by Gibson like there's a force
field around his crease so far in the game cracked
box up follow the bouncing Puck somehow Gibson
and the Ducks did to keep this score 2-1 and a
highy after video review it was confirmed
that the puck did completely cross the
line how about that Dallas with the number 12
PowerPlay unit Duck's 25th penalty killing unit
in the league alas in no problem there here's
Robertson sends it low B pavelski kicked out by
Gibson this is game 48 of the season it's a
2-2 game and very much up for grabs despite
a large shot Advantage favoring Dallas 2513
out in front they score silverberg the net
was lifted up but never came off its pegs from
the back and a centering pass silverberg scores
just 12 seconds into the period this is just
some slop down deep in the star Zone put it in
deep pursue the P straightforward stuff they win
the batt they've scored a couple of goals in the
game where their tenacity on the puck has been
better than the Stars the the for check Tyler
tries to go back there and help out he actually
probably messed things up a little bit can't
fault him for the effort but it didn't turn out
the way they wanted Stars more than it's two to
one shot advantage on Anaheim but trailing in
the game Robertson left Circle save rebound
a couple wax from Ben and Gibson stopped them
all hin it to Robertson shot save Gibs out of
the box Johnston and Gibson freezes donov got
knocked down by kri route to the park on we
go Thomas Harley weaves he's in still
with the left Circle and over to hin
and snaps a shot he scores welcome back
Miro hin in after the 3 we absence as
the game t my goal the Ducks here and
Thomas Harley just sloms his way into
the offensive zone he's trying to lay
one on net and a little floater just
absolutely messes up Gibson I don't know
whether it it touched somebody's hand or
body up front but John Gibson got followed up
on this one no pun intended whether it went off
the glove of mcin shy of 15 this season prior
to the mirro injury here's Leo Carlson cutting
to the inside got the shot away fought for deep
in his crease Andre kept it out and was able to
cover switch of directions and then a hand off
for Terry who's got a goal in the game shot
and AER makes the save only face 20 new cast
for The Stars they've got pavelski hints and
Harley and Peli wins the defensive Zone draw
so first possession of overtime for Dallas
here's Harley charging ahead Thomas Harley he
[Music] scores the overtime winner for Thomas
Harley his 10th of the year and he ends it
with a three-point game and the Stars beat
the Ducks 4 to three disbelief pelski who's
been terrific tonight wins the draw and then
Thomas Harley RPM redlines it all the way
down the rightwing side he's a left shot he
had a gorgeous look at the far side Gibson barely
flinched and for the first time since the 21st of
December Thomas Harley is a goal scorer again
he's had a marvelous game tonight alongside